and on my desk here is a picture of
Albert Yates who's president of the
Colorado State University here on the
right and on the left is Dan Ritchie who
has been involved with the University of
Denver since 1983 he's a Harvard
graduate himself as an MBA he used to
run Westinghouse broadcasting gave this
school what amounts to almost 50 million
dollars in support is the Chancellor
works for nothing a year is standing at
a microphone at 6 o'clock in the morning
at the cable center good morning
Chancellor Ritchie good morning Ryan
it's still night however you can Denver
you know you have a program underway
called bridges to the Future American
history and values in light of September
the 11th what are you trying to
accomplish with this we have a couple of
Englishmen sitting at our desk we're
gonna ask them what American values are
what do you say American values are well
what we're trying to accomplish is to
make people think about the values to
understand why they're so important and
to look at how they may have changed
since the beginning of the Republic and
whether that's a good thing and and
looking forward what should we be
thinking about what should we be vote
should our values be and that's what
we're trying trying to accomplish I
actually wanted to ask you what is your
favorite American value and why is it an
American value and not say a German
value well I would hope it would be a
value everywhere my favorite value is
really integrity and personal integrity
and trustworthiness because without that
nothing works an organization doesn't
work a society doesn't work history
tells us that if it's everybody for him
or herself things don't work very well
and life isn't much fun now as you know
and you quite free to say it that you're
in your 70s and you're still involved
active everyday running a university why
are you working so hard at your age
because I'm in love with the place why
what is it you like well it's an
opportunity I think to to serve and but
to help young people really become all
they can be and to but you know the most
difficult part of this I think is
setting the right example all the time
you know it's the best way to teach is
to set that example and that's what I'm
committed to and why I would get up this
time of day no chance to Ritchie thank
you for getting up this early in the
morning and coming in and joining us
we're gonna turn dude we're gonna turn
to our guests here and then we're gonna
come back to the students who are there
in the room with you this morning and
you folks haven't been here with us for
a while since we last talked christopher
hitchens you've been in gutter or in
guitar depending on how you want to
pronounce them you mingle the woods
concert and gutter but you like to try
if your throat gutturally as with cutter
that's what I've been what did you find
when you were there well it's if we had
a map you'd see the Saudi coast of the
Gulf and you'd see a sort of Peninsula
rather shaped like a palm sticking out
it's a it's a monarchy but it's recently
had a regime change in fact it's the
only Arab country in the last two
decades that has they overthrew the old
king exiled him and sued him for three
billion and missing oil revenues and
then there it's a Wahhabi Muslim state
and society they abolished censorship
gave women the right to vote to run for
office and all the rest of it and then
perhaps best known for this but they
invited Al Jazeera the Arabic satellite
TV station to come to operate from
Gershwin broadcast from there without
censorship they had previously been
trying to accustom Saudi Arabia but the
Saudis wouldn't let them do it so
they're not 40 35 million people who
tuned in to Al Jazeera every every day
and it's it's completely destroyed and
undercut the state monopoly of
broadcasting in the movies in der stadt
means you hear him talk about his trip
over there and we're sure
a map of Qatar on the on the air this
morning and there's a UN vote and just
in a couple of hours what's your what do
you think this country ought to do about
what about the future of the Iraqi
situation I think we should continue to
do what we have been doing which is put
enormous pressure on this despotic and
disgusting regime to actually cuff up
its weapons of mass destruction it's
nerve gas and it's botulism in its and
it's anthrax and it's nuclear weapons
and its chemical weapons or we will go
in there and do it for them and the
question I think is entirely a function
now of Bush's policy for the last two
years of meaning what he says as opposed
to eight years of the United States not
meaning what it says and the message is
getting through and I think the election
has only intensified the pressure on
Saddam is I think a lot of people who
voted meant it to do and so my fear
right now is that Hans Blix sets down
and muddles around like mr. Magoo and
doesn't get anywhere and we lose the
window of opportunity to actually get
rid of this disgusting person and
liberate the people of Iraq from the
tyranny under which they labor we're
going to go to the phones and talk to
the students in just a moment our two
guests Andrew Sullivan and Christopher
Hitchens have done this before
let's go next to the election your take
on the just completed election can I
just finish on Gaza one thing if I say
no then I would have to talk about the
election okay
meekly well the the third grade you
should wave they've been waving my
Vanity Fair piece which has just come
out of a report from this place the
third thing that gutter is have done is
they've taken a side in the struggle
that Andrew is just talking about having
democratized themselves they're very
interested in not living next to a vast
the despotic regime and they've allowed
the United States to build a 15,000 foot
air base in on their soil without asking
particularly what they want it for
and the foreign minister of Gaza is said
recently I don't know for sure this is
true but I've been reliably told it was
true chill flirted back then and said
Sudan was saying look you have one more
chance if you'll surrender we will let
you and your family live in our country
if you'll spare us all what's otherwise
going to happen but that remember the
interview was at an end and I think mr.
Hussein is determined to fight it
through to the last but I think people
will take him up on it let me remind the
audience that Andrew Sullivan calm is up
and active and this morning if you got
on it he tells you that he's don't it
has no excuse for the way it looks this
morning cuz he's been up like let me
start with you I went to bed very early
for me but this is just a rat it's like
I feel like I'm on I'm not nowhere near
in as bad a shape as these poor people
in in Colorado who are blinking in the
middle of the night
talking to us for which I am immensely
grateful but no it's hard for me to get
up at this time of day
a statement from both of you on this
election well I mean it was it took me
by surprise even though I mean I've been
spending the last two years telling
people not to underestimate George Bush
and there I was under estimating him
this was a huge a huge endorsement I
think of his conduct of the war that's
what this is about it's the most
pressing issue facing us and it's also a
huge indictment of the Democrats
negativism bitterness anger and
inability to present a constructive or
positive alternative they had nothing
really to say they said on the economy
we don't like your tax cut but we're not
going to reverse it which is a
completely incoherent position and on
the war they kept saying with for the
war but everybody knew they didn't
really mean it and between someone with
conviction and people who have no
conviction it's a pretty easy decision
for people to make and this is a lesson
we've learned so many times before and
there's a certain the notion Democrats
were hoping to win by blaming the
wealthy or blaming the rich or blaming
Bush or blaming any number of people
this negativism that they
engaged in I think it started with Gore
in 2000 it's continued it's rancid it
doesn't work they've got to start
offering something constructive instead
Chris rehearsin she knows that Henry
Sullivan's been in this country so long
he's starting to lose his accent how
about you
no I haven't noticed that and I've
actually been meaning to speak to him
about this he's so slightly overdone the
the assimilationist Pastor Joe
nobody asked my predictions for the
election which I'm sorry about because
if I'd made them I would have turned out
to be right I hope you pressed in here
well except that I thought I could feel
it coming because I by the simple
expedient asking of myself suppose I was
a registered Democrat which I will admit
I'm not the suppose I was I know a lot
people are what single thing would get
me to the polls I couldn't think of one
I just couldn't imagine one trying my
best to be brilliant for them what do
you think George Bush and so that's a
terrible thing to have to say for a
political party
the second thing but I want to say I
noticed this yesterday the New York
Times during its summary of the Senate
race it gave the percentages races
rather the gay the percentages that
turnout and they also gave the money
spent by each candidate in no case was
the Republican the big spender the
Democrats outspent in all I think that's
new boy with the Terry McAuliffe ization
of the Democrat you didn't ask my
question that what do you think of
George Bush what do I think of George
Bush I think he is I wasn't sound
flippant about this he's a very strong
test of a very important proposition
which is that anyone can be President in
other words he's he's probably the least
qualified guy ever to have run for the
office or even been considered for it
everybody knows that he's not very well
educated not very well-traveled not very
cultured not very smart but he's
actually made a fair job of what ought
to be after all a civil service position
let me just maybe would anyone want to
be able to do it
Yale and Harvard are just reeling having
been educated yellow it means they're
not very well educated I mean the truth
is he he was very well educated as you
say let me say he didn't attend good
schools of thought I mean so did I but I
don't worry education I went to a bell
universe I
I would I would judge him on the basis
what he's done it seems to me that the
achievement that he should have lost in
two thousand by a landslide given the
economic conditions given the incumbent
vice president he should have lost every
debate on those grounds he won every
single one of them any historical
precedent would have shown him losing
gore well I'll go is supposed to be very
well educated of course a lot dimmer
then then Bush turned out to be no I
think you're still under estimating him
which is fine by him okay phones and we
got to get the students involved and
they should know that both these men
were born in England he haven't figured
it out by now both of them went to
Oxford although Andrew Sullivan also
snuck into Harvard for a while and
you've both lived here in the country
for how long
it's nearly 20 years now mr. Hitchens
it's just 21 years you are a citizen
Andrew Sullivan I am NOT you are a
citizen Christopher Hitchens no we both
did were choosing the country of its
dues actually Lexington Kentucky
first up go ahead plays what would you
like to say thank you very much
I just wanted to tell both these guys
I'm huge fans of both of them read
everything they write Christopher
Hitchens weblog is killer Hitchens is a
great writer as a libertarian Republican
here in a red state I'd like to ask both
of them a quick question two quick
questions one is on economic policy what
are the one or two things they'd like to
see Bush do first to get the economy
going secondly what do they think of one
of our local heroes Mitch McConnell who
would like to start mr. Sullivan I would
like to see Bush broaden his tax cuts
not to remove the tax cuts at all I
think they should be made permanent but
I'd like to see them extended further
down the income classes and they have
been I don't think it's good for
conservatism simply to give tax breaks
for the very wealthy I think we need to
give it to all people we need to bring
more people out of out of taxation
altogether I agree with him on the basic
notion that we need to keep taxes low at
this point especially in a troubled
economy but I'd like to see him broaden
his base in that way the last time there
was a Republican midterm sweep with the
Gingrich time they made a promise which
I'd relied to see them keep which is the
people who live in the District of
Columbia don't have to pay the federal
income tax it's because you because well
because we're not allowed to vote
do live in mr. Chloe but I think I'm
still waiting for that that promise that
shining city on the hill give any
opinion Mitch McConnell is gonna be the
number two leader for the Republicans I
didn't know anything about him except
that he was a tremendous foe of the
campaign finance reform let's go to
Chicago Illinois Chicago and then we'll
go out and ask our students get involved
Chicago you're on the air
Chicago are you there Chicago Illinois
are you there yes I'm here please speak
up what why you have to import analyzing
American politics
we do it all the time but how about
getting a comment in here or questioning
and we'll go on with the program list
what if they notice that when the civil
rights bill was I majority the people
that voted Republican were Democrats yes
that's true that is that is probably
Lyndon Johnson Lyndon Johnson is said to
have said as he signed the bill I'm
ready to enact that that was the end of
the Democratic Party in the south his
generation if not longer and but it was
a gamble or if you like him then what he
said whatever he talked about it's not
another risk nor gambling it was it was
a price he was willing to pay why are
you to imports of analyzing American
politics because a free country we can
and because I think we both love this
country and have come here and made it
our own and and and because the great
thing about this country I think unlike
any other country on Earth is that it
will accept wastrels and him like the
two of us with open arms and as it would
as it has always welcomed immigrants for
forever and whether we are with refuse
wretched refuse of the teeming Shore
that's you and me let's leave a sweeping
I mean if there's an implied challenge
from the question which I'd be sad to
think that there was because it very
seldom does come up
I suppose I could claim I'm the father
of three Americans which gives me some
right to comment and I do in fact pay
the federal income tax even though I
three children look without their and
actually I've said in print of the main
effect on September eleventh on me was
to make me decide that I shouldn't put
off taking out citizenship papers
because I realized I had become in
America
I was it was sitting also do it we got
to go to Denver and at the cable Center
in Denver if you've just joined us our
students from Colorado State University
and the University of Denver and they're
involved in out there and I project that
calls is bridges to the future let's ask
our first student to give her name and
school I guess you're gonna give your
first name so we can watch the security
problems go ahead good morning my name
is Bobby and I'm from Colorado State
University and I'd like to pose a
question to each of you gentlemen about
media ethics and and how they influence
our society many of individuals accuse
the media as giving all of our younger
generation bad morals however as our
media just giving us what reality is or
is it what we want to see or is it a
kind of chicken in the egg which comes
first kind of situation Thank You Bobby
Andrew Sullivan um I don't think that
the media is destroying people's morals
I really don't I think that the bottom
line in most media in a free society as
opposed to a closed society is that it
wants to get viewers and that means that
it's desperately trying to give you what
you want which means I think there'll be
a lot of dross out there as well as a
lot of good quality stuff I don't think
there's ever been a time in America and
world history when the choices for media
and for analysis and for news and for
entertainment have ever been this broad
and one of the one of the things about
the internet to toot my own horn and
have had an amazing time for last two
and a half years doing this website is
that you can now publish yourself how
many hits do you get a day last month
1.1 million people 1.1 million visits
came to the site from about a quarter of
a million people for the month every
month two days ago 63,000 visits in one
day let's go back it's now as he was
plugging my book yes the Georgia book
it's go wild will matters very fine
scale very waving at you
you go to and yourself like calm you can
buy christopher hitchens but directly
and help the site as well let's go back
to Colorado next student please my
name's Heather
I'm from Evergreen Colorado I'm from
deal
my question is to both of you do you
think that democracy in Iraq would there
be a regime change do you think
democracy is possible pablo fouet
suggested a sort of denazification
program that happened after World War
two to happen in Iraq and do you think
that it would be possible Gretchen
excellent question Heather I've been in
northern Iraq of the Kurdish areas with
Kurdish and Turkish areas the currently
living under an anglo-american
air cover umbrella have been since the
end of the Oscar for that's to say for
about ten years
in that region there are elections in
the town of Erbil one of the main cities
or 21 newspapers published there's every
sign of a civil society emerging there's
a remember this was this was an area
that was very much wracked before all
this not just by the the poison and
chemical chantix of Saddam Hussein I've
been to the China for dabshe where those
chemical weapons were used there are
people still with burning inflamed
injuries from from it not just that the
terrible the massacres they survived but
they're also quite a lot of inter tribal
rivalry in and Inter conroy recurse on
there's every sign of that somewhat
being overcome so we didn't have to
speculate all that much we know that in
quite a large chunk of the country
that's already been emancipated from
Saddam Hussein's journey there there is
a functioning civil society and the
beginnings of a democracy so I think
that means that those of us who favor
regime change aren't just having to make
it up or rather or perhaps just hope for
the best we know the Iraqi and Kurdish
people's have it in them and they have
the aspiration for democracy and the
education for it and the the thirst for
it to I mean there is a downside as
everybody knows I mean there are there
are religious and and
other differences under the surface but
so there were in in Kurdistan before let
me come back to yours we got a
Cookeville Tennessee next you disagree
with the president go ahead please ah hi
gentlemen if it ought to be on I thank
you for that the previous question which
was posed to Democrats only okay did we
is Democrats favor of the election of a
literal or moderate Minority Leader okay
I personally favor a liberal because I
feel like we need the balance because of
Tom DeLay and Mitch McConnell but I'm
curious as to what your two guests feel
what what do they think would best help
the democratic party thanks Andrew
Sullivan I don't I think the liberal
moderate question is not as significant
ism as a deeper question which is that
the Democratic Party seems to mean has
to figure out what it's for rather than
what it's against you know go around a
campaign against the wealthy against
corporations against bush hours to get
the corporations in the world he to pay
for the campaign yes and no one believed
him in the first place because it was
Cooley put on and the Democrats since
then have been entirely negative it
seems to me that what they need to do is
to be constructive to say if we don't
favor regime change in Iraq then what do
we favor do we favor containment do we
favor sanctions rather than just simply
whining and criticizing if they don't
favor the tax cut then what do they
favor I think what people didn't hear in
the last election was a positive
constructive message I don't think that
matters whether it comes from a liberal
or a moderate what matters is that it's
done positively constructively without
this kind of sneering whiny Terry
McAuliffe sleazy atmosphere that
currently pervades the Democratic
parties mr. Hitchens well as the British
Conservative Party's in the process of
finding out there's nothing that
historically mandates the survival of
political party I mean there's no iron
law that says a party has to go an
existing my friend Patrick Goodell said
to me in 92 when Clinton became the
leader of the Democrats nominee for
president incredibly enough
said that he thought the Democrats would
soon go the way of the Whigs that they
no longer stood for anything that they
lost their resident - they were just a
fundraising and Tammany Hall vote
getting machine that was all and the
things like that are historically
condemned and I read later wrote a book
about the abysmal nature of the Clinton
regime and what I was writing it I
realized that there was there was not
one single thing you could say the
Democratic Party would not do I mean
they they'd given up everything that
gave them what they thought had given
them a moral advantage they rallied
behind in a self evident crook as
president they'd covered up for his
crimes they'd excused them they'd taken
dirty money they they still are the the
most corrupt party I mean the things
that were done in detention goraishi but
by way of raising money on government
time with government faith eclipses or
even what Richard Nixon did we gotta go
back to Denver what's our next students
question yeah I'm Patrick I was
wondering with regards to the internet
and the media how do you see the future
shaping up meaning that you can now
start an online news service on the
internet for basically free there by
taking the power away from just the
wealthy elites to control the media and
how do you think that will shape the
future it's it's it's fabulous and I
advise anybody that wants to make their
voice heard to actually get on there and
do it themselves there's this amazing
new realm of the media out there we're
calling it the blogosphere but it's
basically a lot of amateurs and we're
doing better jobs in the professional
seeing stuff out there that is ignored
and there's no question that we also
have a real problem in the media lead it
is it is blinker to disputed is run by a
small group of people who talk to
themselves the media missed this
election by a longshot the New York
Times last Saturday last Sunday had a
poll showing the Republicans with a
seven-point lead in the generic question
they buried that news because they
didn't want to listen to it they didn't
want to hear it
and when you have mainstream media
things like the New York Times so simply
the news for its own agenda it's
fantastic that there are lots of people
out there conducting guerrilla warfare
putting out the news for themselves it's
a great new era
another student question from the
University of Colorado Denver go ahead
please hi my name is Surya I'm from the
University of Denver my question is to
both of you regarding the vagueness on
this war of terrorism war on terrorism
is it just gonna be like countries we
don't like or is it gonna be everybody
who's invoking fear in their citizens or
anyone who's against America and how do
you what do you think is gonna happen
well I think the word terrorism is was
before all this began suffering badly
from diminishing returns I mean it now
can mean very little more than you know
the willingness to use force in in
politics though it usually means
insurgent force I think we should we
should define this as what it really is
the war on war against theocracy against
the use of against the use and abuse of
religion in international politics and
say we should state plainly that America
stands for secular values within itself
and overseas but will take the side of
those in the Muslim world who do not
want to live under Sharia themselves or
conduct jihad against other people which
is probably a majority so we can't
afford to look at the civil the outcome
of this civil war with indifference
because the the G higher elements hope
to win it by bringing this war to us and
we can't have that obviously we won't
have it but but we are also interested
in seeing that the Muslim civilizations
are not themselves destroyed by jihad a
Muslim society doesn't fall under it so
that's what the war is about and that
would also help you I think determine in
advance who the friends and who the
enemies were I I concur with Christopher
entirely that this is fundamentally a
war a religious war a war against those
who are using religion for political
purposes however I do not think it's a
war for secularism the point of the
American system is that by separating
politics from religion
you give politics Andrew
it's do well we have to explain to the
Muslim world is that under free
government constitutional government
your right to exercise your religion is
stronger and deeper and more indelibly
protected than under any current regime
and despotism under which you labor we
have to tell the Muslim world that we
are fighting for their freedom to
exercise their own faith and that's what
we're doing it's about freedom not
secularism as such I would like to ask
our students out in Colorado if and see
how john splaine is out there Steve
Scully to see if we can get a number of
them to tell us and that that way we can
get a lot more involved here in a little
segment what they think of the idea of
going to war in Iraq and whether or not
they would join if they had to go into
the military just get some sense of what
they're thinking after we take a couple
of calls so you might look around and
see if there are folks are willing to
stand up and tell us what their position
is on all this let's go to Brinley
Michigan you're on the air hi hi I do
agree with President Bush I agree that
he stayed on message during the campaign
well it wasn't his campaign but maybe it
was he stayed on message and Andrew
Sullivan is completely right when he
says that the Democrats didn't stand for
anything they complained and that was it
I do have one question I want to ask is
everybody's complaining about where this
huge amount of money was spent during
the campaigns and yet where did the
money go it didn't leave the economy
it's in the economy it's not like it
just flew up into the air and
disappeared so elections are good for
the economy
thanks mr. Hitchens well that's an
ingenious point I mean I suppose the
elections are certainly they're good in
a way for the media which is one of the
reasons why I think the media often
don't make enough noise about campaign
finance reform which is that's where the
money gets spent that's good Fairfax
Virginia you're on the air oh yes I
think it was well enough that the
President had declared war on terrorism
unfortunately I see that he's not
assembled the correct instrumentalities
it was wish to pursue it what you see is
a global it's a global condition and
it's a real war
and that you need to create you need to
understand what your field of values are
in that field of values I see countries
in that region that more or less tend in
our direction in the direction of arson
arson a system of values I can give you
let's say for as an example India Israel
Turkey the emerging nations of the see I
see us see is Russia and the stance and
all of them are threatened by this by
this phenomenon we should have what we
what the the correct approach should
have been in my opinion would be to
create a dedicated alliance not some
sort of coalition but an alliance in
that region all right sir thanks mr.
Silva I think that's emerging there's no
question that Turkey and Israel are
signing off on the impending war or
impending conflict of some sort but
you've got to be realistic you know you
have to in the diplomatic world assemble
together coalition's that work you've
got to make some compromises in the real
world you've got to understand that
we've got to actually ally in a few
cases with some unsavory characters in
order to get the job done so I do think
there is a coalition building here that
that actually I mean I think people
misunderstand Bush a lot on this they
talk about him as if he's a a unilateral
list a cowboy he's not at all he's a man
who picked Colin Powell to be a
Secretary of State a key part of Bush's
success is the mix he has the mix of
determination ferocity and will with
tactical flexibility and that's why
Rumsfeld Cheney and Powell are such an
important part of the mix stretch well a
slight quote with the grammar of your
question and I think it's it's not that
the president declared war on terrorism
its Islamic fascism declared war on our
studies that's the way around I remember
it and that also leads me to make a
distinction between myself and Angela
about the Arab the Allies matter the two
countries that incubated al-qaeda and
the Taliban
and Finance season helped it and trained
it and some work Saudi Arabia and
Pakistan up until then thought of as
already allies okay
the the great unspoken thing about the
administration's policy because they
can't afford to say it in public either
they've they've realized the total
failure of the client state system the
kind of Nixon doctrine where you try and
rule by proxy through shady
dictatorships like the Saudi oligarchy
or the Pakistani a secret police
Pakistanis have helped you out yet again
you may notice by helping North Korea
show choir missile technology for its
developing nuclear weaponry dumping
these client states means more or less
inevitably you have to play some sort of
better and local democratic procedures
you have to therefore hope for example
that there will be and work towards
democratic elections in Iraq and in this
respect I think the key country is Iran
nearly 70 million people though of
course millions of they were forced to
live overseas by their ghastly
government but they too I think have and
will exert their right of return every
indication is that is that the Iranian
people are on their own without any
outside help out growing and
transcending a theocracy and hoping to
rejoin the Democratic world that that I
think is the that's the hinge event
potential in the region and I think it's
absolutely terrible that the president
and his team have made no public effort
at all to extend the hand of friendship
to Iran to restore diplomatic relations
to resume aid and trade so Iran is not
only treated like a pariah state its
insulted as part of the axis of evil
it's it's an absolutely glaring and
horrific failure on the part that with
all due respect was for that silly the
Fed with all due respect it's it is
either silly or it's not well without
really it's crazy what the what the axis
of evil speech said was that the regime
is evil not the Iranian people who wish
to get rid of that regime and in fact by
making that distinction so clearly Bush
gave enormous hope to the Democrats in
Iran and to the secularists in Iran who
want to topple that disgusting regime
and the most important thing I
agree with you I couldn't agree with you
more Iran is a much more important
strategic country than Iraq but one of
the great goals of regime change in Iraq
is a regime change in Tehran against
those mullahs and I think the policy is
not by reaching out to the government of
Iran as we now have it
we're merely exactly engaging in the in
the cuddling up to dictators that you
oppose we go back to our students in
Denver we have a bunch standing before
the microphones and the purpose of this
little segment is to hear from you
tell us what you think about this whole
situation in Iraq who do we have the
microphone first my name is Paige I'm
from the University of Denver and I
actually have a lot of faith and bushes
as a president but I think our country
really needs has a lot of questions
about war and right now we're just not
ready to fully support because we
haven't gotten enough information and
it's a really scary situation that we've
been put in when the country really
doesn't know what the effect will be for
or against war five ten years down the
road you know we have no idea how that's
going to be affecting our economy and
defense for our country and so right now
we just haven't been given enough
information to fully support President
Bush to go and oh I'm gonna I'm gonna
ask some of the students to thanks Paige
very much make some notes here so we'll
come back to you but how about another
one of our guests out there at the cable
Center go ahead please my name is
Kristen I'm a student at Colorado State
University and I wouldn't say that I'm
for war but I'm definitely for action I
just feel that by non-action against
Iraq that we're just setting ourselves
up to be victims once again and I would
just wonder what how what caliber of a
catastrophic event is gonna have to
occur for us to get our UN allies to
support us in in some type of an action
against them thank you very much let's
go to the next student at the center
what do you have to say about this
potential war situation
I'm Andrea love from the University of
Denver and I agree with Paige saying we
really don't have enough information to
really believe this and I also love the
excuse but we're we waiting for a
mushroom cloud and in my recollection I
could be very wrong but I have yet to
hear of a dictator that attacked the
most powerful country in the world and
expected to live I mean he may be insane
he may be crazy nobody doubts he's evil
but he really likes being in power in it
by attacking the US would really not be
one of the smartest things he's ever
done next student on the other side go
ahead please good morning my name is
Alan I think that we were caught
completely off-guard on September 11th
and I would hate to have that happen
again before this country is aroused in
some kind of response I think that we
can be more proactive against potential
threats to our citizens and I would hate
to lose 3,000 more as we wait and mull
over a decision when there is a decisive
action we're taking right now would you
go to the military if you had to I would
next didn't yeah thanks for joining us
this morning go ahead please okay my
question is do you not fear that if we
do take action in Iraq there'll be even
more recruits happening in al-qaeda and
more even more even more people wanting
to be against America and what about you
how do you feel if somebody said that
they were gonna draft both men and women
for this effort would you go no I would
not next didn't please I was just gonna
say that going to war we've given him a
chance we've given Iraq a chance and
they continue to defy UN sanctions it's
not about the u.s. going to war it's
about following up on the sanctions that
have already been imposed would you go
on the circuit yes absolutely
next student please on the other side hi
I'm Lindsey singleton from Carter State
University and I just think that it's
kind of ironic that we're fighting for
freedom I'm fighting for democracy yet
we see people 40,000 people saying no we
don't I don't think it's a good idea to
go to war against Iraq and and it just
doesn't seem to add up to what we're
standing for what do you say you say
40,000 people say know who you're
talking about
I'm talking about
the the people in Washington who
protested against the war people all
across the world actually alright thank
another student is there one more over
on the other side
go ahead hey my name is Cassie I'm from
Colorado State University and I just
wanted to say I know that a lot of us
don't have the necessary information to
say yes let's go to war but I think
action is necessary and we can't sit
back and just let things happen to us
and not do anything about it I think now
more than ever it's important for
Democrats and Republicans to put faith
in the president and stand behind him
say we're all Americans instead of
trying to hide behind party lines thanks
gentlemen go back to what Paige said we
don't have enough information she said
what do you say to that I'm totally fed
up with hearing that I feel rather feel
a rather strict mood with the students
this way she sounds just like Tom
Daschle used to sound like the president
hasn't made his case go and do some
reading of your own gonna insist gonna
inform yourself who do you think who you
think is going to do the job for you
there are lots of ways of looking this
up there are excellent books tree that's
a very good new one by man named Kenneth
[ __ ] it's produced by the Council on
Foreign Relations it has the terrible
title the threatening storm but it's the
it's the case to beat it's the case you
have to vanquish if you're against
intervention so don't wait to be
spoon-fed on this you should have mugged
up on it by now I would say there is
going to be a meltdown of the Iraqi
regime no matter what bear this in mind
I mean the the Saddam Hussein regime is
in the process of imploding the will
therefore be a post-saddam Iraq to worry
about with a quite a lot of chaos and
instability and misery and violence no
matter what we do the question is
whether we're going to just watch it or
whether the United States and the
international community is going to
involve itself or not I think that makes
it something like a no-brainer I don't
know why Brian asks you why you're or
whether you would care to be soldiers
because it seems to me that
conspicuously in this case of this war
it's more dangerous to be a civilian
than
in the army the whole point about this
war is that it's a Woollett began on our
own soil you I feel that I live in a
quite tall building in downtown
Washington DC I'm much more likely to be
this the object sort of the target of
violence than I would be if I was
wearing a uniform on the American air
strip in in Gaza for example let me let
me address the question that another of
the students asked which is about why
would Saddam do this considering he
might get popped off as a result first
of all he may get popped off anyway from
his own country secondly that's not the
point the point is proxy attacks these
people are very smart rather than
actually doing it themselves they will
get proxy terrorists using their weapons
of mass destruction to do it for us the
other young student talked about 3,000
deaths 3,000 is nothing compared to what
we are in danger of what September 11th
showed us is that what if what if those
planes had nuclear material what if they
had smallpox what if they had the kind
of weapons that we know that Saddam
Hussein has is building is generating
and he's hiding that's the question we
still don't know for example who was
behind the anthrax attacks of last year
that's the genius of the combination of
these rogue states and amorphous
terroristic entities that want to
destroy you and me and our free Way of
life Raleigh North Carolina right come
on in here sorry to keep you waiting
that's okay hi I'm Jane and I was hoping
there was an in-between line because
I've been waiting to hear something and
I think I just heard from Christopher
and mr. Sullivan reasoning enough that
I'm now on the agree with the president
side most appreciative of c-span most
appreciative also as mr. Sullivan
mentions about the news that is
available where as in years past decade
ago maybe maybe even five years ago that
was soaked and that was so controlled by
a few people it is thrilling that we now
have more access to as close as we're
going to get to the truth
argue do you go on the internet yourself
yes I do and I kind of you know surf
around and I've been on those websites
before that you have represented this
morning worldnetdaily as well and just
try to keep myself informed and that was
going to be my comment well I don't know
yet because I'm just trying to listen to
those who perhaps have more access to
information than I do but Christopher
Hitchens just made the point what more
do I need
thanks Karl let's go to Falls Church
Virginia you don't agree the president
tell us why well I I can't I have a
taste for his I don't particularly care
for him because he has a taste for the
gutter exemplified by his and his
jackals that saxby chambliss his attack
on the patriotism of Max Cleland a man
who paid a catastrophic price in a war
that Bush and Chambliss took a pass on
but my question is for Christopher
Hitchens what gives me pause is you
wrote in your Nation column withdrawing
from the nation that one reason that the
Left should support a war to liberate
Iraq is because an abiding cause of the
left over the last few decades has been
the Kurds but don't you think there's a
very real possibility that in order to
appease Turkey in order to ensure
turkeys cooperation that the US will
turn a blind eye to to a savage
repression on on behalf of the by the
Turks against the Kurds in order to keep
the Kurds from declaring their own state
and since as you said they've developed
their own civil civil society do you
feel that we're being endangered by they
would feel emboldened to declare their
own independence and then Turkey would
would say well not so fast okay well for
those who don't know the background to
this thank you for the question the
Kurds are the largest people in the
world without a nation state of their we
have actually know quite how many there
are of them probably 24 25 million at
least and they live
unfortunately for them just where the
borders of Iran Iraq Turkey and Syria
meet isn't a very hospitable area and
they're protected mainly by their by
their skills as Mountain dwellers
they've always been a Hill people and
that's what's kept them going well look
it's it's true that if you if you
encourage Kurdish autonomy in any one of
those countries you encourage in the
neighboring ones too and neither Iran
Turkey nor Syria certainly not ever want
to see the emergence of a stronger
Kurdish autonomy but they are going to
see what no matter what happens the
European Union for example at the moment
is blocking the admission of Turkey to
its ranks it's a a club that even the
Islamist party that just won the
election will very much wants to join
they say well you can't join until
you've given more guarantees of autonomy
for your vast Kurdish population in
effect recognized there are two nations
with inside Chucky's I don't really
think the United States can offer the
Kurds less than that and since they
aren't have been our allies and are
already fighting against saddam hussein
and have already partially defeated him
i think they have a very reasonable
chance of coming out of this ahead but
you're quite right there will be
pressure from people on in the
conservative ranks here and the people
who are the friends of the Turkish
government to water down the commitment
to catastrophic IRA so I hope people
will be will be vigilant about it Andrew
Sullivan what do you - now disagree
about I mean we first invited you here
some time ago and there was a lot of
disagreement you sound like you to come
from the same side now no I don't think
we do at all I mean Christopher is a man
of the left and I'm not I think that
it's more interesting to see why we
agree and why we agree is because I
think we both saw on September 11
something really quite astonishing and
we saw around us week sums weakness not
in the general population at all among
up here is about recognizing what that
threat was encountering it and that
common purpose should overcome I think
any of our ideological differences at
this moment in time we are we are war
against a truly dangerous
theocratic islamist enemy and from my
point of view whether we agree or
disagree about redistributing wealth
whether we agree or disagree about our
religious faith whether we agree or
disagree about any number of other
domestic issues should be put aside for
the moment not always and i havnt don't
agree with him on many things because of
the current crisis and that and i think
that i think that was the message will
serve this election during the truth I
think people were saying look we're not
gonna stop being Democrats we disagree
with all sorts of issues there are all
sorts of internal debate in this country
and thank God for it but at this moment
in time we have a president that we
trust and we want to prosecute and win
this war by the way the debate starts at
about 10 o'clock in the UN and they
expect between 60 and 90 minutes of
discretion before the vote comes
Christopher Hitchens and Andrew Sullivan
are at our table this morning and we're
joined by over 40 students from both
Colorado State University and the
University of Denver in Denver at the
cable Center which was constructed by
the cable television industry put on the
campus as an educational spot run by Jim
O'Brien and we have a bunch of students
at ten minutes of six o'clock their time
that are up but no ten minutes of 7:00
their time up and about and we want to
go back and hear some more from our
students tell us your first name and
give us your comment on all this hi I'm
Jessica and I am from Colorado State
University and I wanted to ask both you
gentlemen a question and my question is
do you really feel that this war in Iraq
will solve a problem or do you think
it's just gonna put a bandaid on a
bigger problem that exists in our world
today thank you let's go to another
student we'll come back and get a bunch
of reaction and questions in here go
ahead hello my name is Diana and I was
just curious as to what you gentlemen
think the UN's role should be in the war
against terror UN's role and the war
against terror let's go back to the
other side go ahead please we've got a
question go ahead my name is Annie am
with the University of Denver I was
actually wondering we talked a lot about
media bias and if either of you see the
media bias either way and
on top of that how we should keep
ourselves best informed outside of any
kind of bias let me ask you do you see
media bias I think that we see a bias
towards wealth here and most of the
major media venues are controlled by
money and you can make arguments that
it's liberal because liberals can afford
or they can afford to be liberal or that
they're owned by major corporations so
it's more conservatives it goes both
ways I think thanks let's go to another
student in Denver go ahead please please
go ahead that's professor go ahead good
morning everybody
I'm Youngman I'm from I'm a visiting
scholar from China I'm against the
possible a possible war to Iraq one of
the reason for Bush to make a possible
war to Iraq is that Iraq violates UN UN
resolution of course UN's resolution
should have be respect by other
countries but there are still some
countries in the world
pull that violate UN resolutions for
example Israel what was US government's
attitude to it
Thanks thanks professor we will get the
point of the question do you have a
comment on that last question from the
professor I mean is of course right the
the I think the Israeli supporting
wrapped up the largest number of UN
condemnation for their the appalling
mistreatment of the non-jewish
population the other population of
Palestine and it's now admitted by
everyone and even the President himself
has become the first American president
to use the words Palestinian and state
in the same sentence and in opposition
to one another
that there are two peoples in past
islands that there should be a two-state
solution but in the meantime it seems
that Israel is to suffer no penalty for
its repeated violations not just of the
resolutions but of the rights that the
UN stands for and embodies and this is a
very serious negation in my view my view
and it's the thing that threatens to
jeopardize the whole project of American
sponsorship of regime change in the
region because if seen as the military
ally of a racist bully and killer like
Ariel Sharon the whole appeal of the
event project is to the extent
diminished of course it's a very very
serious problem indeed at the
professor's identified one reason that
Israel is in violation of some of those
resolutions they're not not that many
not as many as you would think it's
because they face the same problem that
we do of of terrorism of suicide bombers
of people who are not interested
whatsoever in making peace with Israel
but in destroying Israel groups like
Hezbollah groups like the Palestinian
entity that are basically also partly
funded by people like Saddam and indeed
the Islamists who want to destroy the
State of Israel and that join with
Saddam and the Saudis and many other
Arab regimes in a fanatical Hitlerian
anti-semitism the wants to see Israel
taken off the map now the other
difference is quite obvious Israel is
not threatening the world with giving
terrorist entities weapons of mass
destruction to destroy other countries
and innocent civilians Saddam is and
that's an absolutely clear distinction
which makes the priority obviously
Israel did illegally by piracy and
deception acquire a nuclear arsenal it's
in flagrant violation of the
non-proliferation treaty or maintains it
still yes and if it weren't for that
which it weren't for its defensive
sitting there with 1/10 of 1% of the
land that Arabs have if it didn't have
those defenses it would have been
obliterated long ago and you know it and
you know your cities surrounding powers
want Israel destroyed now let's think
almost none of them even a
knowledge its right to exist and a
fermenting terrorism against its
civilians which is exactly the same as
the Terrorism fermented against us the
UN resolutions through been violated you
told where all these violations occurred
well before anyone had heard of or
before the war such an organization as
Hezbollah which arose incidentally in
response to a completely illegal Israeli
aggression and occupation in south
Lebanon you deny that Hezbollah has very
close ties with Islamist fundamentalism
and terrorism Hezbollah it means a party
of God so why you want definitely gives
a clue about his views about the oxy you
have you who arguing terrorism giving
Hezbollah a pass as well I was was the
organizer of the resistance to go to an
illegal criminal Israeli occupation or
don't you know they had every right that
they had under international law every
right to resist and repelled that
occupation don't you think of this that
you could use the same argument about
al-qaeda resisting the tyranny in Saudi
Arabia
well quite obviously not al-qaeda is no
fun you know your honor is fighting to
establish flags you actually defend
terrorism when it's directed against
Israel but not against the rest of the
world it is no it is not it is not
terroristic 411 it's not terroristic to
have suicide so heuristic for Lebanese
citizen to resist a foreign occupation
in this country has in Lebanese citizens
resisting anything is bullying is about
the destruction of Israel the use of
terroristic tactics to kill innocent
civilians now why can't you condemn
that's what I mean by the enemy that's
what I meant earlier I drew when I said
that the word terrorist was become
effectively useless because of
propaganda zation and diminishing so you
are you ask you you will not continue to
the international law gives the right to
the questions and the Lebanese to resist
the Japanese as you know full well the
Haider is a complete I was not a
guerrilla organization fighting
occupation Hizbullah
is an international terrorist group
funded in part from the mullahs in Iran
that you despise and it you will not
condemn it for its suicide attacks upon
you on Israel and its and its use of
terror I guess I'm emphasizing what
isn't obvious hundred okay besides just
for the record what is obvious that his
bullet is our enemy gotta go back to the
phone's Meadville Oregon you're on the
air
go ahead please a good morning hey you
know if if Hezbollah wants to fight
that's fine but they don't need to go
blow themselves up in the middle uh you
know populated areas get their get an
army and go fight you know that's
ridiculous they're terrorists actually
that's what they do did we did doing
sells everything you could see them out
in the open you still can
did you have another point me to go I do
it's Syrian controlled Lebanon it isn't
it's it's nonsense to recall these
Lebanese so this is this is a Syrian
satrapy controlled by a vicious
anti-semitic dictator who was using
terrorist tactics to destroy the State
of Israel come on back I got just one
more thing I'd like to say this this
business that we got going all around
the world look it's all academic if we
don't all stand together you know the
Democrats can't snivel you know and
everybody else we all better stand
together and fight terrorism or we're
gonna we're gonna have a sad state of
affairs there ain't gonna be no America
no more there won't be no Europe no more
will live in seventh century and we'll
all learn how to say it all wow thanks
Bel Air Ohio you disagree the president
what would you like to say this morning
hello hi you're on the air okay yeah
Chrisman questions I disagree with the
president we have a inconsistent foreign
policy which is pretty obvious but I've
heard a couple things recently a guy
named John Curtis who work for the
Reagan administration said that there
was a Kuwaiti slant drilling into Iraq
prior to the Persian Gulf War and I
wonder if this was true and that Saddam
looked for different methods to deal
with that Thanks I believe that it is
true there was there was Kuwait he
Sandra Lane before the last Gulf War and
there is always has always been a
question about a border dispute which in
Iraq and Kuwait involving the remaining
oil field and the small islands booby on
in war whether just off the curstyn it's
quite possible that the Iraqis have some
claim they're certainly Iraqi
governments prior to the Saddam Hussein
regime thought that erupted and indeed
Kuwait was initially detached by force
by British colonialism from Iraq many
Iraqi nationalists think of it as a lost
province of the
country but that wouldn't justify the
annexation of the whole of Kuwait by
forcing the putting of the population of
Kuwait City more or less to the sword by
Saddam Hussein which is what actually
did happen this is also part of the
problem of the left right now you keep
going back finding inconsistencies
finding things we did wrong in the past
try to find any kind of red herring
apart from the fundamental prices we now
face are we going to tackle the threat
of terrorism which has already declared
war on United States or are we not stop
it if I were to give you advice stop
this sort of long litany of
anti-american grievances and understand
put those behind you and go from now if
we did for example this the point
Christopher has made very eloquently
let's say we did at some point in the
past disgracefully aid Saddam doesn't
that make it more incumbent upon us
today to rectify that error instead the
left wants to go back and back on its
bitterness on its anti-american trip and
it's getting nowhere and the people are
sick of it we need to go back to our
group in Colorado there's a lot standing
up at the microphones we want to hear
from a bunch of you go ahead out there
tell us what you think or what you want
to ask hi my name is Nikki I'm from the
University of Denver well first just a
really quick comment I do
really agree with Chris Hutchins on his
comments on Palestine and I really
applaud you for that and sorry to be
going back to the Iraq thing but where
do you if we do go to war with Iraq
where do you think we should stop should
we start an invasion on Korea because
now they have weapons of mass
destruction where do you think that line
should be drawn next question from
Colorado go ahead please my name is
Katie and I'm a junior at the University
of Denver and I know we've been speaking
a lot in specifics but my question is
more in the general sense of we've been
talking about setting a lot of values
and Chancellor su talked about integrity
I was just wondering what you think are
some attainable goals that we can set
and what actions we can take to achieve
these values and do people really all
have the potential to make a difference
next question from Colorado other side
go ahead please my name is Jessica and
I'm also from Colorado State University
we
been talking again a lot about values
and whatnot and we know that journalists
hold themselves to a set of values that
they've outlined do you think that they
also hold a moral obligation to society
let me ask you what you think at a good
American value is Jessica um we were
actually asked this last night and mine
was education I think that education is
the building block to get anybody to
anywhere next side what do you say
what's your question what's your comment
my question is what do both these
gentlemen think about Scott Ritter's
claims about the weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq what do you think of
it I think he has a lot of valid points
and I think it's important to know that
he's a primary source instead of
listening to what other people have to
say because he's actually been there and
he is a former UN weapons inspector so
why didn't you let me ask you why do you
believe him and not any of the other
inspectors and none of them have said
the same things he said it's not that I
don't believe it but I think he has a
lot of valid points about what we've
been doing for the past ten years with
the sanctions and the destruction has
been causing the Iraqi people and I
don't understand how it's going to help
them if we bomb them thanks rose let's
go to the other side again go ahead
please hi I'm Sam from the University of
Denver and my question was is I have two
things first you actually think we're
gonna go to war with Iraq and if we do
do you think will have more terrorist
acts occur because after 9/11 and like
the anthrax scare there haven't really
been many more like terrorist acts but
if we go to our war with Iraq do you
think other terrorist groups will react
in other ways Sam what's your instincts
are we going to go to war um I hope you
don't but I'm not really sure if you are
next side please go ahead Denver you're
on hi I'm Andrea from the University of
Denver and I just come on bring up the
point they were talking about all these
3,000 Americans that have died
well the thousands of people that die
every day every week in Iraq because we
bombed their water treatment facilities
and their electricity plans and all
these sanctions on them I think we go to
war we can like we have more less remote
control planes with bombs on them we can
be 500 miles away and we don't in
trouble yet we're bombing these people
we can't see
and we've been doing this for four years
now yeah now we're just trying to
declare war now where is the justice in
this Wow 3,000 Americans thousands of
them
Iraqi citizens every week die next side
please go ahead my name is Tom I'm a do
you student I think it's interesting
there have been several polls about
whether we should go to war and one poll
is should we just go to war and with
that question people generally say yes
but when the when it's added that we may
lose American lives in the war the poll
results go down with less people wanting
war it's very obvious that you can't win
a war without ground troops I was
wondering do does and is anybody taking
into consideration that we're gonna lose
lives on the ground in Iraq thanks let's
stop there for a moment and pick up any
of those things you wanna comment yes a
lot of them first click I'd like to
caution everybody I do this all the time
don't say war on Iraq gents a war with
Iraq there's no one wants that and there
isn't gonna be one there is gonna be a
conflict with Saddam Hussein an
intervention to remove Saddam Hussein
from the leadership of Iraq that's a
quite different thing morally as it is
politically and it's just it's just in
the in the language people are talking
about it as if it was other than what it
is now I'd like to take two of the
questions at least Scott Ritter claims
to know more than he can possibly know
it's as simple as that what he no one
can know what he says he knows you'd
have to have had a regime change in Iraq
and a complete inspection already before
you could certify what he's certified
but it isn't claimed that Iraq yet has
for example or Saddam Hussein I'm doing
it myself now Saddam Hussein has nuclear
weapons it is claimed that he's it's
asserted he's not going to be allowed to
get them we're not going to find out
what it would be like if you did have
them thus to your point about North
Korea where I've also been I'm quite
well upon my axis by the way I've been
to North Korea and Iraq and I've been to
both sides of the DMZ in Korea and the
the impressive fact about that very
bleak landscape is fantastic
concentration of force and violence and
weaponry is that the Capitals
South Korea Seoul is about 20 miles
south of it which means it would be
destroyed in the first round of any
renewed Korean War the war would end
with the destruction of the North Korean
regime - but it would start with the
destruction of the capital city of a
major democracy now we know the North
Koreans have uranium rods they are in a
position where they can talk deterrence
where they can they can impress us with
their deterrent effect
just imagine if Saddam Hussein was in in
that position that's what you have to do
Syria I think was there was its Araya
and not sure how to question earlier -
which we didn't get back to but others
have brought up though what if this
makes more people dislike us this how it
roughly goes sometimes it's what if it
makes more people join al-qaeda I think
this is not really pessimistic question
in a way this every chance that a huge
number of Iraqis the majority of them
will will welcome an intervention to
remove Saddam Hussein I certainly don't
know myself any Iraqi or Kurd who
doesn't hope for it round the clock
second the al-qaeda forces appear for
some reason to dislike us anyway I don't
really see how they could hate us any
more I wouldn't mind giving them
something they could really hate me
about like we removing a man who they
seem to admire mr. mr. Saddam Hussein
and if if that makes more people join
al-qaeda well that that's that's more
casualties for al-qaeda to take they
want to be martyrs we're here to help
Anderson let me just ask you Sam asked
whether or not you think we're going to
go to war and won't that cause more
terrorist activities in this country
there's no evidence that when we've
actually tackled these fascists and
murderers that they have been successful
in getting more recruits in fact the
opposite is the case
since we went into Afghanistan a war
that lots of people also opposed where
has been the huge al Qaeda up where has
been the great uprising of the Arab
Street it doesn't happen it has never
been an example in which it has happened
that part of the world first of all has
two things they're desperate for
democracy they're stifled by their own
regimes in Iraq and elsewhere they want
to actually have regime change and they
also respect power and our conviction
the only thing that can keep those
people enslaved
is our own weakness and secondly on the
North Korea thing it's a fantastic
example because there we have a
situation in 94 well we had news and
evidence that they were developing
weapons of mass destruction and you had
two choices confront them or appease
them and Clinton and Carter constructed
a policy of dialogue of talk of peace
negotiations of incentives engaging
these murderous tyrants who was starving
their own people as if they were
reasonable human beings we find out six
or seven or eight years later lo and
behold they ignored us they built a
nuclear bomb or the capacity for a
nuclear bomb anyway now imagine if
Saddam Hussein has a nuclear capacity we
can do nothing any war against him would
lead to nuclear complication he then has
the entire territory that he controls as
a launchpad for every vile terrorist
organization in the world if we wait if
we do not take him on then we are
essentially creating the possibility for
far bigger war far worse conflict far
more deaths than we do if we go in now
it's just like if we'd stopped Hitler in
1936 rather than 1939 so much awful
devastation and loss would have been
avoided the question is not war or peace
the question is war now or war later you
gotta grab a phone call Hatfield
Massachusetts you're on the air
I can warning so you spent think of - I
call appreciate it good morning
gentleman mr. Sullivan is applying clear
logic to the equation your enemies can't
hate you any more than they already do
so have no fear when you attack them and
you know I think that I'll just take 20
seconds here I think that the the
difference between rogue outlaw
state-sponsored terrorists who finance
and assist any international terrorist
group but that Nexus of weapons of mass
destruction rogue outlaws state sponsors
and terrorists international terrorist
groups is a is a sphere and a risk that
we can't ignore I also think that
President Al Gore had become president
that he would have chose to apply the
same logic to this and I would like to
get the gentleman's response today do
they estimate that a president a
president gore
responded similarly to the way President
Bush's responding mr. hitchens no sir I
do not I mean a man who cracked up over
a recount in Florida and they receive
burst into tears and grew a beard and
went all runny as someone I'm very glad
was not president on the 11th of
September and as for his choice of a
vice president what can I say no we we I
I don't actually believe that there's a
special Providence that watches over the
United States I wish I could believe in
such a thing I don't but it's tempting
sometimes to think we might be in the we
were this close to having those guys in
charge that day and I my mind refuses to
to engage with how ghastly you thought
that is either Afghanistan would now be
a glaring smoldering ruin or it would
still be run by the Taliban one or other
of this I think would be the like this
Sylvania hatboro go ahead please you're
on the air yes good morning I'd like to
ask them just one question to your panel
their name me one thing directly that
Iraq has done to the United States
directly not what they're building up
not what their what their what their
what they're going to do they have not
done one thing directly to the United
States this would be the first time this
country has ever attacked another
country that has not attacked them now
I'd like to listen to what your panel
has to say well it isn't the United
States versus the Saddam Hussein regime
it's the United Nations at the
international community as you must have
noticed they the resolutions are
unanimous and binding as far as I know
unless you exempt the possibility which
some serious people do entertain that
the first bombing of the World Trade
Center had an Iraqi super police hand in
it if I'm I'm agnostic about that by the
way there is no example of the sort you
see but you would you wouldn't need it
this is an enforcement of international
law and international status mr. stone
it's also true that Saddam killed many
American soldiers and allied soldiers in
the first Gulf War after violating
international law so there are actually
families of people in this country whose
sons and daughters were killed by that
man
hatboro would you want to come back on
both these gentlemen and give us your
comments
absolutely oh we and when they attacked
they would we attacked them in the
Desert Storm excuse me we invaded Kuwait
I mean this is like saying we attacked
Hitler first I mean it's absurd just go
back and read your history I know my
history you know let me finish
number one we came over to protect
Kuwait because they invaded Kuwait
because they had a border dispute we
were over there to protect Kuwait we
attacked them they defended ourselves
and they again attacked our soldiers
just the same as anybody else in this
country would do the same if we were if
they were in fact leave it leave it I
think that should speak for itself I
think let's go back to Denver what do
you say students please go ahead
hi I'm Hillary Hillary from the
University of Denver and I was just
wondering um last night we also spoke of
two other values that we hold strong
here and those are unity and patriotism
and I was just wondering if you think
that the unity and patriotism within the
US has changed you do the divided
thoughts on whether or not to go to war
with Iraq Hillary would you tell us for
those people watching what you're
talking about when you say last night
what's what are you involved in um well
we've got the University of Denver and
Colorado State University together last
night two different classes from each
school and they we basically sat down
and discussed what we thought were
important values for our country right
now and overall what did you learn from
that discussion um well I think that I
have I have a lot of the same views as a
lot of people um that I spoke with last
night and that were speaking and I think
that I just haven't been able to put
into one word a certain value that I
hold strong and last night I was able to
see different words that could define
how I feel as well let me say that I
think that there is a very important
distinction between the concept of unity
and the country concept of patriotism in
a democracy we don't have to be unified
to be patriotic in fact
on the contrary it seems to be important
and and and extremely good that in this
country in the last election we had
basically a 5347 split which is a
extremely closely divided country even
though President Bush won a big victory
compare that with the pseudo awful
disgusting elections in which Saddam
Hussein got a hundred percent but no one
down to vote and a hundred percent
turnout let's go back to Denver next
student please hi Kristina from Colorado
State University we've been talking
about privacy lately on campus and in
the university and I was wondering what
you gentlemen feel in our current
situation how we can maintain security
without our personal privacy being truly
affected do you feel your own personal
privacy that is threatened not at this
moment but I feel if we did go to war it
would definitely be invaded a lot more
than it is now
Thanks next student please go ahead hi
my name is Jesse and I'm from Colorado
State and I was just wondering what you
three gentlemen think about what
American value we should remember during
the current crisis what one would you
like to remember during this crisis I
think trust and respect for each other
and ourselves and our leaders is
important trust and respect for
ourselves and our leaders mr. Sullivan I
would use the the virtue of courage this
is a very scary time we live in I think
we live now under the threat of and
possibly the inevitability of an attack
upon us with chemical biological or even
nuclear weapons just because it hasn't
happened in the last year or so doesn't
mean it cannot happen or will not happen
and we look around us and war is also a
terrifying and awful thing and we don't
see an easy solution to any of these
things in those circumstances we have to
express fortitude and courage in facing
the threats not running away from them
not denying them and then also I think
moderation we want to go through with
this war with restraint clarity and
prudence I don't think we want an
impulsive or reckless war we want
something that was going to make the
world a safer place not
a more dangerous place Farmington
Connecticut you're on the air um good
morning my problem was President Bush's
policy towards Iraq is what I see is a
double standard or hypocrisy at the same
time that President Bush condemns Iraq
for certain issues such as terrorizing
neighbors he gets in bed with the Red
Chinese he has a problem the red Chinese
threat and certainly said in their
neighbors Taiwan the red Chinese have
conquered a neighboring country Tibet
and subjected as people and destroyed a
culture the Red Chinese have had taken
down an American plane and international
airspace and helped American soldiers
prisoner Red Chinese weapons were found
in lk ik caves in Afghanistan the very
same standards that George Bush is
applying against Iraq and his intentions
to liberate the country apply towards
Red China Plus Red John has weapons of
mass destruction destruction targeted at
American cities but he has the premier
of China at his ranch in Texas what's
the difference plus de KT as CEO of
Halliburton would bought oil from Iraq
you know what's the big threat reaction
well I must say it makes me feel young
again to hear the words Red China
pronounced with such menace and so and
if I may say so so often also in the
same question the the some countries are
too big to stand up against I mean I
will let you into a secret of
realpolitik
we detest for example what the Russians
and formerly the Soviet Union do in
Chechnya but there's nothing we can all
propose to do about it that's your big
to stand up against the the charges you
make against Red China as far as I could
tell all of them true except I don't
think they help to arm our qaeda they'd
also face a Muslim insurgency within
their own borders and for this reason
our willing to be friendly with United
States and remember now they have a vote
on their permanent member of the
security council so they will get much
nicer treatment than another country
would if say it
you didn't doubt by the way there's a
they repeatedly invade or threatened
with invasion Vietnam but there it is
there it is you know he mentioned Taiwan
an entire Thai bear - but no Vietnam by
the way which is close the country close
to my heart so there it is I'm afraid
they're just too big and they both got
vetoes on the or the UN Security Council
on a different note on my desk here is a
cartoon from the New York Times a couple
weeks ago by Robert Grossman it's in a
column by Judith silhouettes and it
shows a man named Orwell crawling across
the ground and two little figures on his
back this one is supposed to be Andrew
Sullivan and this one is supposed to be
you you look like a little angel there's
the Grossman came up to me the other day
at a party in New York and he I think he
wanted to apologize for for this
caricature I said no no leave it the way
it is it's it's too flattering for words
but you look like he looks like the
Christopher Robin that we all knew in
love what does what do you look like
here Andrew Solomon leaves that for
others he's certainly got the plaid
shirt right but what's the going on here
between the two because I know you've
been dialoguing as they say on the
Internet
here's the book why Orwell matters we
have students out there that are
studying people like or old I suspect or
do you suspect they're studying well I
hope so and then again I hope not
because in a way it's it's death for an
author to become a set book I mean he
becomes respectable and compulsory and I
think a lot of people have been made to
read Animal Farm and 1984 I think that's
it's so likelier than not that that's
become a compulsory book I wrote my book
partly to restore oh well as a figure of
controversy as someone who was always in
his lifetime involved in in important
fights on that was a principle he never
would have expected to become a sort of
teacher's pet or or role model but it's
still essential that people read in
every level oh it was a socialist or his
life and quite a I mean of quite a hard
left definition of that to anti
Stalinist but more towards the left
opposition
the sometimes called trots kiss but you
you rot I did yes some of the best years
of my life like after that learned a lot
from it it was on this program a program
where you admitted that you were no
longer a slave I have to say Riverside
Illinois go ahead please you're on the
air
Riverside please go ahead good morning
gentlemen hi I have a question but first
it seems to me that if the students were
allowed a broader range of oversight for
example I personally have deliberately
joined organizations of the left the
right for example I joined the National
Organization for Women and the ACLU and
believe it or not the John Birch Society
and the publication's I subscribe to our
broad mix both of yours by the way and
it's fascinating and one can only seem
to come down on the on the right after
reading all of these if the students
were to do that if they were a repeat
permitted to has a broad reading scope I
think there would be less confusion in
some of their statements however it
isn't permitted under the academic
regimen we find throughout the country
today Connor just stay right stay where
you're I want to ask one of the students
who's at the microphone first of all to
introduce themselves who's the gentleman
there tell us your name again Allen
Allen our caller from Riverside Illinois
suggest that you're not given a broad
range of reading in your classes would
you agree with him I think that's a
fairly absurd statement did perhaps if
where our curriculum is more of a
liberal leaning but it's more more upon
ourselves to look at other sources of
information whether it's more
conservative information or perhaps more
liberal information that's that's kind
of our our charter students to broaden
our scope if we feel that what we're
getting in class is not sufficient let
me ask the other student at the
microphone if she would like to tell us
her name and then tell us whether or not
you think the professors in your class
have a broad broad enough range of
reading my name is Molly and I'm from
Colorado State University and I
definitely think we have a broad range
of reading
that's my only comment on that my
question actually for you gentlemen was
what is your idea of the ideal American
president and what single most important
value do you feel that the president
should hold I'm gonna hold on that to
just a second to go back to our
Riverside Illinois call her they suggest
that they've got enough out there in the
way of breath you know we bought the
upsets and the tearing up of the
newspaper stairs to co-sign on something
from opposing the general trend and
academia appears they go out and steal
the papers I know there are certain
publications well written at the New
York City Journal for example seems to
me to be an excellent read and presents
things a bit differently than and I
believe his name is Theodore something
or other who a doctor from England also
he he writes in the City Journal quite a
bit
oh I'm nervous Dalrymple I believe his
name is no time at the new school in New
York you have the honor of addressing
the professor of Liberal Studies
completely and insisting a being it's
only how often I get the stretch but
pressing solemnly along pedagogical a
long what I can tell the younger
audience members is this if you if you
think you're what you claim you are well
read or what education you're not all
you the best you can hope to do is to
find out how how ill read you are that's
what education does it shows you that
roughly how much you still have to learn
so to say to say I'd say I've already
read enough or I know I'm a well-rounded
person or another is by definition
untrue I'm sorry and I think that's part
of the problem here is the cult of
self-esteem which is true in education
today it's like people kids are taught
what students are taught that the most
important thing is to believe in
yourself and
that you're the best thing that ever
happened as opposed to tell them you
don't know anything none of us know
anything and all of us the students our
entire life you've got to get out there
find out new material think about new
things people talked earlier about
wealth in the media the truth is that's
all your ecstatics Cuse is over buddy
the Internet is free a site like mine
cost nothing to read I don't get paid
for it it's all about getting
information out there and learning and
there's never been less of an excuse for
a smug lazy student to claim that he has
or she has a broad education and I wish
more teachers today will tell their
students that they don't even know the
half of it yet and get out there and
learn more guys are on a roll would you
like to continue mr. right
no I big that I want you to say more
about oh well for a second well you
might sell a full week yes no do one
from other book what do you want just
you might see the cover again that looks
here let me hold it up just breathe it's
that as everyone knows about the 1984
or well modeled his horrific concept of
a hermetic future totally closed and
tyrannical and hateful society on things
that had already happened that heat
airships in Germany and Russia but the
reason why he's relevant still is if you
go to North Korea or to Iraq you would
have met you would imagine these people
had modeled their state on Orwell that
they've taken 1984 thought could we make
this work could we make people that
miserable that frightened that coerced
round-the-clock could it be done well
we'll give it our best shot I think
people have some have a difficulty when
all of these discussions we've been
having about Iraq and North Korea this
morning in getting their minds around
the concept of radical evil of even
though the president says something's
evil it might still be true that there
are dictatorships so horrifying that you
wouldn't be able to imagine living in
them for a day but the vage a plan just
to keep it at that they have they have
plans to try and inflict this misery
further and there is a temptation among
people of
liberal temper and torrent mentality
among so reflective intellectuals - in
some ways to turn away from that to say
no it can't be that bad
surely there must be some reasonable
compromise we can come to here the rest
of George Orwell's life as you can't
compromise with Churchill fairness and
at home as well or abroad
look he's $24 buy basic books in case
you're interested in coming up in 30
minutes we go to the UN they'll have a
debate 60 to 90 minutes and a vote on
the UN resolution that everybody's
reporting will be passed 14 to will be
one abstention Syria and the rest are so
are reportedly on board on this our
buses today are in Orlando and in Omaha
Nebraska the c-spine school buses will
be here for 30 minutes with the students
from Colorado State University and the
University of Denver they're located out
the cable Center which is on the
University of Denver campus our guests
are Christopher Hitchens and Andrew
Sullivan who has a website called Andrew
Sullivan dot-com about to promote you
and you don't want to interrupt Athens
Georgia you're on the air go ahead
please I just wanted to ask particularly
mr. Sullivan about his views on
selectively looking at history because I
think in the past 50 years the US has
not really studied history we've gotten
involved in Panama in Chile and Zaire in
lots of places and we really didn't see
a long-term what we were hoping to
achieve we just wanted to replace a
particular regime and all we've done is
cause worse problems for the people
there oh and here we go again let me
counter that by saying absolutely we had
a goal in this country of the last 50
years that goal was to defeat the other
totalitarian system the Soviet Union to
liberate half the world from its
tyrannical disgusting rule and if you
look at South America if you look at
Eastern Europe if you look at whole
swaths of the world that now live in
democracy that didn't before the one
major difference between that and
tyranny was the United States of America
I am so so tired of this blame America
first attitude I thought we've gotten
rid of it and part of the problem is
that the left won't let go of that they
still suspect this country more than
they suspect any other country in the
and until they let that go until they
actually rediscover the valleys of what
this country stood for I'm going to
leave in it they're politically dead
bring anthems back in and we'll get to
you go ahead Athens you still there
Athens is gone you're gonna say snot mr.
hitchens well I think I did
I hope Andrea doesn't mean what he just
said because it would be to say that we
have no responsibility at all we must
forget any consideration of
responsibility for things like the
destruction of the democratic process in
Chile the murder of purchased the Mamba
in the Congo the devastation of Cambodia
and Laos in Vietnam the mass murder and
East Timor none of these things by the
way did anything to bring down the
Berlin Wall Andrew these were acts of
imperial violence and bullying we live
still with their consequences
there are unpunished war criminals like
Henry Kissinger amongst us and if people
talk as if well we don't we don't owe
anyone an explanation for this that's
well we had no long-term goal that we
had no real idea what we were doing we
didn't understand history of course
Christopher this country must be held
morally responsible for the consequences
actions in a complicated world and of
course things have been done in this
country that are shameful and wrong as
in every regime but in the broad
perspective in the broad historical look
there's no question this country has
been a force for good in fact without
this country without the United States
both Nazism and Sabich communism would
prevailed and that's the difference
between freedom and tyranny and the
United States was the difference and you
know both of us grew up in a country
that knows that very very clearly I may
go back to Denver students at the
microphone tell us who you are and
what's your comment or question hi my
name is Jake and from the University of
Denver and I was curious what you guys
thought about the role of the United
States is the police force of the world
and if it's become too great that's it
thank you how about let's go into the
other side Paige you're back with us
what would you like to say in this time
yes my inquiry actually really bounces
off of what you guys just were talking
about and AI you just like say commend
what the two guests were just talking
about about life being a continuing
education and we're never really fully
there but how does the United States
democracy really compare positive and
negatively internationally as far as
politics go Thanks we have three
questions from the students in the last
few minutes one of them is what's an
ideal American president remember that
one and then what's your feeling about
the role of the US as a police force
around the world and then how does the
United States is democracy compare with
others those are three things I think
you all think about ideal American
president well I should start by saying
because we will show us about ideal
American value I mean if I was to say
what the value was I hope I'd come up
with a better way than integrity by the
way again I still think there is
probably too much esteem washing around
the base that's a tautology if you have
value you have integrity of have
integrity to have value I would say for
America the thing that has magnetized me
to it and did is is it some respect for
the Constitution and in particular for
the Bill of Rights it's a country now it
was founded on written documents that
are subject to revision and to review
and it's the only one that is founded on
such promises and I would this is part
of the answer to a subsequent question
there's no country I know including my
own him to initially the United Kingdom
that wouldn't be better off if it had
opted the Bill of Rights is there does
that constitute the u.s. role as the
police force that when I was American
also has a revolutionary role as the
police force well you know that I have
two views up I just said to Andrew that
I think that has been a disgraceful a
record of imperialism and bullying in
the past but the the it's heartening
therefore to see a country that once we
American didn't extinguish the
democratic process in Chile the Nixon
kissing a gang did that but America
through a long process of debate and
discussion is considering sponsoring an
election process in Iraq that's all
that's all the differences your movie
that you're involved in the trials of
Henry Kissinger available around the
country well it lasts no network would
take it because there were such wimps
and cowards but as Andrew says the day
of the monopoly in the media is is
to limit extent that's true of movies to
instill arthouse type cinemas or one in
one in Washington one in two in San
Francisco Film Forum in New York you can
catch it and you can you can make an
effort to if you're in a college town
you can make an effort to have its
haven't shown that Andrew Sullivan the
role of the u.s. is a police force the
ideal American president this democracy
let me take greatest upholder the
Constitution and the Union was obviously
I would have meant it and in the most
dire circumstance it's overcooked for
that it seems to me he takes the part
the value which I hate that where the
virtue is better a value sounds like
this sort of interchangeable amorphous
equality is is the defense of liberty
period I mean that's what it's about
if it's not about that it's about the
pursuit of happiness and this wonderful
the idea that a country would put the
word happy happy in its constitution is
such a wonderful idea it's that every
human being might have a different idea
of what it is to be happy and not only
that but not the attainment of happiness
but the pursuit of it even when you fail
if you don't get it right that process
of getting it right that process indeed
it's all about process which liberty
gives you that's what I'd love about
this country and it's I'm forever
grateful for it giving me the space and
air to breathe as someone who who I
think would find it very hard to fit in
anywhere else as to the president I
think that one thing we miss is
something that's very intangible about
political leadership and that is simply
judgment the ability to weigh a question
in real time
without knowing everything about the
possible consequences because nobody
ever does I mean going to war for
example is an absolutely terrifying
notion we can't know for sure but having
the skill and the ability to measure a
particular moment in time and make the
right decision is is what the ancients
used to call prudence or practical
wisdom you don't have to be book smart
to do that you just have to have
judgment I actually think that our
current president has it I think people
understand that he doesn't have to have
read you know Solzhenitsyn or Dostoevsky
or Kafka or or Machiavelli or Aristotle
or George Orwell but he has it and just
as Truman has it and I must say to
counteract Christopher the idea that
he's unqualified was unqualified having
been a two-term governor of one a huge
state in Texas educated all the best
places compared to someone like Jimmy
Carter he's immensely qualified and
indeed compared to someone like Harry
Truman I want to tell our audience those
of those teachers in the audience we've
been offering you that free large
timeline of American presidents told you
a couple weeks ago we had 25,000
teachers that were answering up we're
now over 41,000 and we keep rolling with
this so those teachers out there that
are interested in having us in the
classroom it's about six by four feet
c-span org and look for c-span org slice
education or slice classroom and you'll
find it
c-span org slice classroom we have about
22 minutes till we go to the UN we have
Silver Spring Maryland on the line go
ahead please I'm Butterfield but I could
not say that anyhow I support George
Bush removing Saddam Hussein because
please don't cut me those people are
existing and surviving they are not
living life but on the other way
Christopher is honest journalist he no
history he is very good person
and Salamone he loves I think Israel
more than America because he cause
problem for America he wants we want war
war war war war look at Europe how
peaceful it is where did you say you're
from I'm from me to appear I'm well
friend of Israel we don't hate Israel
but America should get peace you know we
need peace all right thanks Miami
Florida go ahead please run here yes
please hello yes go ahead please yes I
just have a comment America become a
bully class of the a bullet the
classroom and this is what's causing all
the problems in the world I don't
understand why the jurors have such
double standard everywhere in the world
if he's talking about revenue mass
destructions so why he does not read
every country who have it the same way
to Israel have it too and everyone knows
that
and of course Russia have it and China
have it and I only saw your program and
that guy talked about China
and America really does not care only
obviously about what they want because
they managed to visit a China about
Taiwan Taiwan is part of China and if
it's up to vote even to decide what's
going to happen while you butcher knows
there if somebody comes and takes Hawaii
and split it up you're gonna take it and
other Qing to Israel it treats the
middle is very very badly the
Palestinian look what's happened to the
Palestinian everywhere and no one says
anything that's double standard to and
almost when there is a Christian people
somewhere in the world they want to
split like in an East Timor America
behind him a hundred percent but if
there's some Muslim people who won
sovereignty anywhere in the world
America stands against it remind you
that we remind you that the last two
major Wars this country was engaged in
both in the Balkans and in and in the
Gulf were in defense of Muslims and
American lies have put on the line to
defend the Muslim minority under the
fascist aggression of slobodan milosevic
so this is just baloney I'm afraid also
to say that the United States was 100%
behind these Timor is is illiterate as
well as well sectarian I think is what
I'd have to call your attitude sir I
don't if you think the United States
goes around the world looking for
Christian minorities to to protect a
Muslim wants to to oppose I think you're
you're merely a religious sectarian
Miami were you from originally
embarrassing and I'm a very proud
American I'm against Saddam Hussein I
wish he never got to power at all I know
it is his dooble bad but he treated his
people but when he was in our live
United States he
chemical weapon maneuver than alive
United States in the early nineties and
late 80s and no one says anything now
you say all that it's true I say nobody
says anything you remember he said no
one ever says anything about the
Palestinians you must know that's not
true presume also if your person you
would know that perhaps 20% of them are
not Muslims that there are the
Christians or of Noah of no faith it's
it's ridiculous to look at the world in
terms of your your confessional
allegiance you'll feel much better when
you start
sighs they don't say nothing about them
but if they're not there I lies you
attack us Spencer
Thanks okay back to the students what do
you have to say out there in Denver what
school are you from give us your first
name please
hi my name is Abby and I'm from college
State University and my question is do
you think the American media has created
a faucet to help concerning the war on
terrorism do you a B um I think it had
in the beginning because I thought we
were doing all right you know with our
efforts
you know bombings whatever we're kind of
helping we're putting a dent on what we
needed to and then later it's like well
it really didn't do much so what's your
attitude about the potential of
potential war with as mr. Hitchens would
say Saddam um when I think of war it's
kind of frightening I I go back and
forth like sometimes I'm like we need to
create peace and not war and then other
times like sometimes you gotta take
those necessary measures to take out
those people out of all you're gonna get
around to sorting that out instead of
just feeling these things I'm doing that
right now I don't really I'm amazed at
the gender imbalance over there
I mean to know men get up in the moment
get up in the morning but it's it's
interesting to me this is another
function of how well women are doing
colleges and in education around the
country I mean what's amazing is that
we're getting a fantastic gender gap now
in colleges and educated people in which
women are our trouncing men I want to
wear all of the men out there why aren't
they in that in that in that room let's
go to the other side and see if we can
find one of the men's students
there's hardly anyone up there please
give us your name this is fine anyway hi
I'm summer and I'm from Colorado State
and we've been talking about this virtue
of trust in our government and I find it
very hard with the current
inconsistencies in foreign policy and I
was just wondering how you gentlemen
felt about that would you want to
specify an inconsistency um such as with
Iraq we opted for a regime change and
with North Korea were more into
containment and determined cause we just
did that cause that's because the North
Koreans already have the nuclear
capacity once they get it you're Anna
terribly difficult spot to counter it
and we have to thank Bill Clinton and
Jimmy Carter for helping North Korea to
get a nuclear capacity summer what do
you say about that um I guess I would
have to say that to me North Korea is a
bigger threat and I think that we should
be focusing on them we're in the news
every day we're focusing on Iraq I know
perhaps you missed my gentle but
authoritative take on this earlier we've
done this I don't know when you when you
showed up but I totally well I had been
to the DMZ in Korea noticed at the
capital city of South Korea so big
capital of democratic country now is
only 20 miles away how it would it would
be destroyed in the first round of
anywhere renewed Korean hostilities this
is too high a price to pay if it can if
it can be avoided and it looks as if
it's possible that can be makes it very
different indeed from the situation
where there aren't you you don't
remember my saying any of this how
disappointing let's go to another
student please in Colorado go ahead
please I had a comment for Andrew
Sullivan and I was wondering you know
why you have the feeling that we need to
just move on and not focus on the past I
think it's important for us to look at
the past and look
what our country has done both good and
bad in order to understand what's going
on today
and not just say oh we'll stop whining
and no as long as it is in [ __ ] you
from action in the present or doing good
things right now of course nothing that
I said should be interpreted to mean
that we shouldn't examine our history
however I do think that examining
American history of the past 50 years we
should give people a lot to be proud of
in terms of what it has been able to do
in expanding freedom and ending tyranny
around the world it's not without its
blemishes goodness knows absolutely and
I and I commend Christopher for brewing
attention to those blemishes I seek
judge in Vermont you're on the air
thank you for taking my call first I
believe war has been declared on us and
whether we can debate the issue now we
will eventually have to respond to it my
question concerns inherent evil and
humans are capable of great good and
great evil and obviously this conflict
and what's been declared on us is fueled
by passion and I want to know from the
gentlemen if they think that removing or
containing Saddam Hussein will will take
care of the assure whether someone else
will just come forward to replace him it
will not solve the issue for good there
will be further dangers there are other
entities there is Tehran there is Syria
there is places people organizations
like Hezbollah who want to continue the
war and will have to go on in in the
real world there's no final you know end
to anything war especially against evil
is constant in every generation the
question for our generation is whether
we can recognize it when it's in our
midst and act against it because
previous generations have failed
sometimes to do that in a timely fashion
yet Minnesota you're on the air good
morning I can't understand why we're
having all the talk about war just like
deciding who can kill the most and then
sit around and talk about trying to
settle it there's been practically no
mentioned
a year or so about getting together and
trying to settle things in advance and
then if they can't then decide who can
kill the most but why don't we get
together with Saddam Hussein with a
summit meeting and other nations and try
and reverse the situation of the world
and get to a modern civilization and
come to some senses to try and settle
things without being primitive cavemen
type people who can kill the most
scholar what why do you think we're not
well we don't hear anything about it
very practically no news comments about
real effort forced confrontation to talk
about it and decide what can be done the
world have had 11 years of dialogue and
sanctions and any number of attempts of
resolutions to get Saddam not to be a
menace to the world and to his own
people 11 years of talking I don't know
how much more talking we have to do
Connor what do you say that
I've never heard about any big meetings
between Saddam Hussein and the rest of
the world
well said if he's kind of a hard guy to
get to see he didn't even turn out until
the last day of his own 100 percent
election campaign the other day he
doesn't receive many visitors or many
guests he sends out as an voice I could
instance one person I know his name is
now she Sabra you've seen him he's the
guy with the eighth piece suit of the
smirk of shaking hands with Jacques
Chirac he's the Foreign Minister up he
has two brothers both of them being
tortured busted I was saying only one to
death the other not quite to death what
in your business mr. [ __ ] Sabri goes
around as a broken hollow robotic
hostage Sian's envoi that's what he
thinks about us is that he he'll send
he'll send out he'll send out his some
his to his morally destroyed prisoners
or story about Tariq Aziz his son
oh the Tariq Aziz who used to be the
foreign ministers now Deputy Prime
Minister has a son who was some senators
last year took 20 years imprisonment
was released then was re-arrested then
released again then realized to Turk has
his knows who's boss he's the other guy
you see shaking hands with Kofi Annan
Saddam Hussein uses hollowed out
humiliated hostages as his nobility last
comment for the day and I'm just like
see the gentleman perfectly illustrating
my point some people can't believe that
there is real evil and cruelty and
madness on this scale that the most
surely reasonable men can get yeah what
do you say wrong been told about all the
evil than that and I believe it I think
it's true but I don't hear any concrete
evidence of forcing discussion among
various people in the world Saddam and
others because I think we're going to
see more and more terrorism and it's
gonna be here certainly well beyond my
lifetime all right sir thanks let's go
back to Colorado Jessica last year at
the microphone what would you like to
say to us I'm a student at the
University of Denver and I was just
wondering if you think that our war on
terrorism is a form of cultural
imperialism what do you think I think
personally that it is that we're
imposing
what we think are the universal laws but
we're not taking into consideration
other cultures and how they've been
living and what they think is right mr.
Sullivan where do we start
no one's forcing anybody to believe
anything except the mullahs and
dictators in those countries who will
not allow anybody to think otherwise
than the way they want us to think we
are a free country they are slaves women
in that part of the world which you
think is such a wonderful cultural
example are covered from head to foot
cannot vote in some places cannot drive
kind of even get out of their houses now
you believe that that's a wonderful
example of cultural diversity I think
it's obscene and attack upon the basic
rights of women and I'm amazed to hear a
young woman student defend that kind of
enslavement of women across the world
yes Kay you want to say anything not
even when I'm bringing up I'm just
saying that conceptions that we think
that we know what is
which is nari lucious is it cultural
imperialism to believe that the
enslavement of women is wrong I
personally don't believe that it's the
right thing to do to go into another
country and tell them what we think is
right let me ask Ann to ask you that
question one more time do you think that
the enslavement of women is cultural
imperialism I mean do you think the
opposing the enslavement of women is
cultural imperialism and we should be
ambivalent about that no personally I
don't but I don't think thank you why
don't you stand up for your own beliefs
let me go to another student on the
other side please we're running out of
time hold on mr. Hitchens please speak
up tell us who you are
hi I'm Kendra from Colorado State
University and I had a question for the
two men about the value of safety in the
u.s. involving the war I think it's
really important and if you question
some people question if we go to war
like it might threaten the u.s. safety
but we have to quote we have to ask
ourselves how safe are we now so I think
we should have the courage to stand up
and do something about it mr. Hitchens
value of safety I think that speaks for
itself but I'm so preoccupied with I
think was a Jessica before actually what
Andrew says about the treatment of women
or the maltreated of women though it's
formally correct doesn't apply to Iraq
but would apply to Saudi Arabia because
Saudi Arabia is our ally and they're a
few will address Co is is your problem
because the United States actually
doesn't try and impose its own values on
a lot of its allies it doesn't it's even
willing to surrender that me tried to
let the Saudis tell American soldiers
who the sorry said invasion on their
soil that they couldn't drive if they
were female or they couldn't wear a
cross or a Star of David if they were
Jewish or Christian because a non
Islamic religions are banned in Saudi
Arabia
we're running out west and as they're
not it's in a way the United States is
is often not judgmental
enough but what you're advising me to
say is I do I think my our values are
superior anyway well I think the values
of the Bill of Rights are superior to
the values of the theocratic
dictatorship that that doesn't mean they
need be imposed but it means they must
be defended we're running out of time
and and ER there are three
students standing at the microphone
without I hear from all three of them
before this is over give us your name
finally good time go ahead and who
finally gets a break morning thank you
for being here my name is grant I
graduated from the University of Denver
last year and I had the privilege of
being in the class with Doc's plane I
thank you guys for being here and my
comment is that I think regardless of
what issue we're talking about the most
important thing is that we need to
obtain accurate information and I don't
think that always happens in a textbook
like many universities I think my
education was liberally biased at D U
but it was my responsibility to go out
there and find other resources and to
check the information I've had the
incredible privilege of traveling to
Western Europe and also to Nepal and
from some of my real world real world
experiences you learned that there's so
many different perspectives out there
and a lot of times I think as Americans
we don't get all those we have done some
amazingly courageous things in our
history I don't agree with all of them
but I do believe in the freedom in
America and I think we have an
incredible resource the internet to get
accurate information that would just
encourage all the students here today
and also our viewers to do that student
feeling you're only getting one side of
the story in college you can log on to
Andrew Sullivan comm and get a whole
range of different to use Thank You
Gregg sounds like a budding Christopher
Hitchens traveling around the world like
that next student please good morning
my name is Kevin Mullin and I go to
Colorado State University my question
are actually a question that was imposed
to us last night was a do we feel as
though we are the September 11th
generation and I think that's a
premature title to put on our generation
being as though we're 20 21 and maybe
older and if you guys think that that is
an appropriate title for our generation
in the light of many things to come
thanks Kevin one more I think we have
one more at the microphone we're running
out of time go ahead hi mark from the
University of Denver I think a lot of
the apprehension that the some of us
show in the war against Saddam Hussein
is that it started out as a war against
against Osama bin Laden in in
Afghanistan and then kind of seemed to
switch somewhere to weapons a weapons
problem and it seems that that President
Bush has been using the impetus behind
September 11th to push this war a little
bit further and faster
and most of us are comfortable with
thank you Kevin and and I mean Marc and
everybody else out there the students
who participated for getting up to
chance to Richie for getting up real
early and coming to us at 6 o'clock your
time Jim O'Brien who runs the center
there and Doc's plane who's on the scene
we have a little bit of time left - the
two of you the September 11th generation
is that fair well in a way it could be a
badge of honor to be called that I
suppose but there is something a bit
final about it it's as if the word there
be anything else to talk about either to
serve rate or to deplore I think I would
want to resist it if I was his age
anyway I since I think it's true to say
that it changed everybody's life and
certainly changed mine I didn't really
think it's a generational question how
do you think it is or if it is that
we're all of that generation no because
I think when you I think that all of us
are very strongly affected by the first
event that happens in our lives that
really does change our attitude toward
the world that has a major impact you
can see the boomer generation is
completely made by the Vietnam War and
Watergate I do think that this event
showing the fragility of American lives
showing that we're not invulnerable will
have a huge psychological impact on this
generation I think will make them more
realistic about the world more
determined to do good things in the
world and more determined to defend the
values that they believe in all of which
is I think is a good thing now let me
just address the September 11th Iraq
question the issue is very simple in a
way it seems to me what September 11th
showed was that these people are capable
of anything
they're prepared to kill people innocent
people in large numbers now we also know
that the what makes this particular era
particularly dangerous is technology
enabling these people to get access to
things that could make a disaster like
September 11th see minor in comparison I
think we'll be lucky if we call the
September eleventh generation there
isn't another date that will live in
greater infamy when these people get a
hold of weapons of mass destruction and
the biggest and most dangerous supplier
of such weapons of mass destruction
surely has to be Saddam that's the
connection do you want September 11th
with nukes again or do you not and can
we wait
wait for that to happen or do we stop it
now Christopher Hitchens the UN we're
going to be Security Council 15 members
China's in the president's seat for this
month
do you like the yarn do I like the whip
huh it's a good place what I like the
idea of it I wrote it I read a very
short book about it was suggesting more
two ways in which it could be improved
but it's two very good question one I'm
afraid
I mean yes the the UN is progress it's
an improvement over the League of
Nations it's an improvement over the war
of all against all it probably it's too
much reflects the the the balance of
power as it was in the Cold War I'm
going to thank Andrew Sullivan who you
can find at Andrew Sullivan dot-com
every day it's constantly updated here's
it writes in the middle of the night do
you live here I know it's you're in
Provincetown I'm moving between living
in Provincetown and here half the year
half there and Christopher Hitchens this
book again will show them is called why
Orwell matters thank you in your
bookstores $24 basic books go through
hundreds thousands excellent website are
you going back again to anywhere other
than the United States but someplace in
the world do whatever just come back
from Gaza what I would really like to
just go back to northern Iraq and I'm
hoping to do that soon you're the
current yes and and see of those because
there's also going to be a big meeting
of the Iraqi and Kurdish opposition
surgeon to plan for what I keep saying
this but I'll end on it too we know
we're already in the post-saddam Iran
we're just on the threshold if fall is
just going to happen anyway whether we
will it or not the Saddam Hussein regime
doomed for a long time is now doomed
itself on your screen now is American
master to the UN John Negroponte II as
he walks toward the the hall where
they're going to continue this debate
these are UN cameras that we're looking
at they're the only ones allowed in at
this point and will watch this debate
and watch them assemble inside the